ah
cannonball you'll excuse me I got to get
back to slacking off precious we talked
about this it's hard to respect your
personal space when it tastes like
peanut butter look at all of you lazy is
toiled on your back take it easy Andy
it's not like the nuts on spinach whoa
oh the peanut butter was in there I'll
find a new place even better than the
nut shop pretty in the picture perfect
Liberty Park generation zero profit I
got bigger plants and trees and
amusement park they're going to destroy
the park the fat guy with a dining
shovel how much damage could he do oh I
get it
tiny shovel was a symbolic gesture this
park is worth fighting for
I got this let's see you drive down
[Music]
I'm good but you guys get the next one
my crazy plans don't work they'll follow
you anywhere surely you can do it that's
all you know
it's not only if you want to stop these
guys it's gonna be every man let's go
get off what are you doing roll over
I don't know how I'm not classically
trained
you like it the very existence of this
game offends me we were overrun by
enemies mangy little rodents don't get a
boy
[Music]
got to be a safety violation
oh sorry
you